d'hélène avait 17 ans lorsqu'il s'est
retrouvé en situation d'itinérance pour
la première fois j'ai commencé par
dormir sur les planches et chez des amis
sur les sauf chez des amis puis il a
cogné aux portes de différentes
ressources d'hébergement mais difficile
d'obtenir de l'aide
surtout qu hélène étrange ans des fois
les refusent ça peut être subtil on va
dire ford présente pour qu'on fasse un
test visuel de ce thé suffisamment gros
pour pouvoir accéder à la ressource eau
ce nom on craint pour sa sécurité
le problème à l'heure actuelle il n'y a
pas de ressources dédiées à la
communauté lgbt qu plus particulièrement
aux personnes transgenres
pourtant le besoin est réel que un jeune
transe sur trois qui se voient refuser
l'accès à un hébergement sur la base de
son identité de genre
de plus on estime que près du tiers des
jeunes en situation d'itinérance sont
issus de la communauté lgbt q c'est deux
à trois fois plus que parmi la
population canadienne donc c'est
préoccupant c'est des besoins qui sont
quand même urgent donc puis il ya quand
même une belle ouverture puis une
reconnaissance de l'ensemble des acteurs
c'est pourquoi des groupes lgbt qu ont
formé une coalition
il travaille actuellement à améliorer la
situation
ils veulent d'abord intégrer le réseau
de l'itinérance puis former et
sensibiliser le personnel qui y
travaille on pense que ce serait
nécessaire d'avoir aussi une ressource
spécifique de continuer le travail de
formation de soutien d'accompagnement au
sein d'eads et du personnel des
ressources existantes actuellement au
canada seule toronto et saskatoon ont
une ressource du genre quant à d'hélène
il est convaincu qu'il faut faire bouger
les choses pour éviter que d'autres
jeunes transgenres comme lui ne se
heurte à une porte close
c'est comme si je te disais attrape la
balle mais que tu avais des mains
pleines de l'est
non mais franchement c'est ta photo s'il
te plaît choisi le chemin le plus facile
ici qui me permettrait au canada
montréal